Sammy came to Libya from Nigeria in 2019
with the hopes of Crossing into Europe
he was detained at Sea by the Coast
Guard and sent back to Libya Sami says
he spent eight months in a detention
center before being released two weeks
ago
did not allow us to cross Libya people
did not allow us to cross every time
they catch you if you didn't catch you
maybe he told you deportation it will
know better then catch you then put you
in prison Libya has long been a Transit
hub for migrants from other African
nations trying to reach European Shores
so far this year more than 25 000
migrants and refugees have reached Italy
from Libya while more than six thousand
were intercepted at Sea and brought back
to the country
the U.N has described the central
Mediterranean as the most dangerous
Maritime Crossing in the world with more
than twenty thousand recorded deaths
since 2014. so far this year at least
650 people have died and more than 300
are missing at scene the un's migration
agency says there are more than 700 000
migrants in Libya 89 percent of them
cited economic difficulties in their
countries for coming to Libya the
oil-rich nation has been engulfed in
Conflict for more than a decade but
experts say a stable Libya could help
decrease the number of people attempting
a dangerous Journey Crossing to Europe
if in the near future we see elections
being held in better Economic Security
and political stability in Libya the job
market will increase so there'll be no
need to cross to Europe Amin came to
Libya from Niger more than 10 years ago
he's been working at this restaurant in
misrata ever since he says he hopes to
open his own restaurant one day I don't
want to go to Europe I'm comfortable
here I'm happy with my job I come in do
my work and get paid on time thanks to
God I'm doing very well financially and
able to support my family back home
says more than 80 percent of his staff
are migrants
foreign workers are extremely important
to Libya Amin is essential to our
business he started off as a cleaner but
he has been promoted three times and is
now an assistant chef
for some migrants like amine there's
little interest in going to Europe he
says a stable and good income in Libya
that helps support his family back home
is all he really needs Malik trainer Al
Jazeera misrata